This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vidantam. In 1950, before he directed the film on the waterfront, Elia Kazan made another dramatic thriller, a movie called Panic in the Streets. There's a reason you probably haven't heard of it. It is in a great movie. Here with recorded is the story of a silent savage menace, the events, incidents and emotions of the people who are apart of it. It is in a great movie. Here with recorded is the story of a silent savage menace, the events, incidents and emotions of the people who were apart of it, who found time running out as they looked into the face
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维丹塔姆。1950年，在他执导电影《码头风云》之前，伊利亚·卡赞拍过另一部惊悚剧情片，叫《危险的角落》。你可能没听说过这部电影，这是有原因的。它不是一部伟大的电影。这里记录的是一个无声而残忍的威胁的故事，是卷入其中的人们所经历的事件、遭遇和情感。它不是一部伟大的电影。这里记录的是一个无声而残忍的威胁的故事，是那些发现时间在流逝、直面生死关头的人们所经历的事件、遭遇和情感
of mortal peril. The film tells the fictional story of a murder in New Orleans. When the police investigate, they find the victim suffered from a deadly infectious disease, a version of the plague. Public health officials believe the killers may have contracted the disease as they carried the victim's body away. What follows is a race to track down the criminals and halt an epidemic, a collision of law enforcement and public health. If the killer is incubating humanic plague, he can start spreading it within 48 hours. 48 hours? Yes, we have 48 hours. law enforcement and public health.
这部电影讲述了新奥尔良发生的一起虚构谋杀案。当警察展开调查时，他们发现受害者患有一种致命的传染病，一种鼠疫的变体。公共卫生官员认为，凶手在搬运受害者尸体时可能感染了这种病毒。接下来是一场追捕罪犯、阻止疫情蔓延的竞赛，执法部门与公共卫生部门在此交锋。如果凶手正处于人类鼠疫的潜伏期，他可以在48小时内开始传播病毒。48小时？是的，我们只有48小时。执法部门与公共卫生部门。
Today on the show, we have a story where life imitates art. It's a story about disease and panic, but it's also a story about psychology. To control an epidemic takes more than medical skill. It requires an understanding of human behavior and the forces that drive people to act in certain ways. Our story starts in Munrovia, the capital of Liberia. A deadly crisis was sparking fear, news reports were filled with dramatic language and catastrophic warnings. The Ebola virus is back to its end.
今天的节目中，我们有一个艺术模仿生活的故事。这是一个关于疾病和恐慌的故事，但也是一个关于心理学的故事。控制疫情需要的不仅仅是医疗技术。它需要对人类行为以及驱使人们做出特定行为的力量有所理解。我们的故事从利比里亚首都蒙罗维亚开始。一场致命的危机正在点燃恐惧，新闻报道中充满了戏剧化的语言和灾难性的警告。埃博拉病毒卷土重来。
Ebola breakout in West Africa is, quote, totally out of control. A catastrophe is unfolding. The world's deadliest outbreak of Ebola. Highly infectious, quick to kill with no vaccine and no cure. The Ebola outbreak reached its peak in the fall of 2014. By the end of the year, it was subsiding. But then, in early 2015, in a poor part of Mondrovia, there was a new outbreak or cluster.
西非的埃博拉疫情用他们的话说“彻底失控了”。一场灾难正在上演。世界历史上最致命的埃博拉疫情。高度传染性，致死极快，没有疫苗，也没有药可治。埃博拉疫情在2014年秋季达到顶峰。到年底时，疫情正在消退。但随后，在2015年初，蒙罗维亚的一个贫困地区出现了新一轮疫情或聚集性病例。
And it led to the complex case we're focusing on today. I got a call from someone who said, if your passport isn't in my office in the next two hours, you won't make your flight to Liberia. Ethelia Christie is an epidemiologist with a Centers for Disease Control and Prevention or CDC. She flew to Mondrovia to help track and stop the outbreak. Lots of CDC officials joined her, like Frank Mahoney.
这直接引出了我们今天关注的复杂案例。我接到一个电话，对方说：“如果你的护照在接下来两个小时内没到我办公室，你就赶不上飞往利比里亚的航班了。”埃塞莉娅·克里斯蒂是美国疾病控制与预防中心（简称CDC）的一名流行病学家。她飞往蒙罗维亚，协助追踪和阻止疫情。许多CDC官员与她同行，比如弗兰克·马霍尼。
People were scared. It was a crisis. You could drive through the city and see people that were being left out on the street, you know, for people to come pick them up. Frank and Athelia told me how the case we're following today started. Police in Mondrovia discovered a body in a warehouse. A young man dead with multiple staplons. Police were called in. A swab was taken as mandated by the official policy that any dead body be swabbed.
人们很害怕。这是一场危机。你开车穿过城市，会看到有人被遗弃在街上，等人来接他们。弗兰克和埃塞莉娅向我讲述了我们今天追踪的这个案例是如何开始的。蒙罗维亚的警察在一个仓库里发现了一具尸体。一个年轻人死了，身上有多处刺伤。警察被叫了过去。按照官方政策的规定，任何死尸都必须进行拭子采样。
So even though the police who arrived there initially thought they were investigating a murder, they did follow the procedures and have the body swabbed, at which point we were alerted because the test came back positive. Positive for Ebola. Once police identified the youth, they quickly realized they had a major problem on their hands.
所以，尽管最初到达那里的警察以为自己在调查一桩谋杀案，但他们确实遵循了程序并对尸体进行了采样，正是在这个时候，我们收到了警报，因为检测结果呈阳性。埃博拉病毒呈阳性。一旦警察确认了这名年轻人的身份，他们很快意识到自己遇到了一个大麻烦。
It turned out the young man was actually part of a large street gang. Yeah, it was like a gang. One of them, for whatever reason, he got stabbed by other members of the group. As we understand it, there was a knife fight, and we're not quite sure how it happened, but the friends turned on him. Just a review. A young man contracts Ebola, he gets in a fight, and it stabbed repeatedly by fellow members of his gang.
事实证明，这个年轻人实际上是一个大型街头帮派的成员。是的，就像一个黑帮。不知什么原因，他被同伙给捅了。据我们所了解，当时发生了一场持刀斗殴，我们不太清楚具体是怎么回事，但朋友们背叛了他。回顾一下。一个年轻人感染了埃博拉，他卷入了一场斗殴，并被帮派同伙多次捅伤。
Ebola remember is highly contagious, come into contact with an infected person's sweat or blood and you could fall sick too. The gang had as many as 35 members, each had connections far and wide across the city. And just like in that movie, Panic in the Streets, public health officials needed to quickly stop the outbreak from spreading. They needed to try and find every person who could have come into contact with the young man.
记住，埃博拉具有高度传染性，接触感染者的汗液或血液，你也可能会生病。这个帮派多达35名成员，每个人都在城市各处有着广泛的联系。就像电影《危险的角落》里一样，公共卫生官员需要迅速阻止疫情蔓延。他们需要努力找到所有可能与这名年轻人有过接触的人。
It's a process called contact tracing. It's exceedingly difficult to do if If you tried to imagine constructing the last three weeks of your life and determining every single person that you came into contact with, whether it was casual contact or a family member who you saw every day, it's extraordinarily difficult to do. So we interview people multiple times. And we also talk to their family members and their friends
这个过程被称为接触者追踪。这极其困难。如果你试着想象梳理你过去三周的生活，并确定你接触过的每一个人，无论是泛泛之交还是每天都见面的家庭成员，这都是极其困难的。所以我们要对人们进行多次采访。我们还要与他们的家人和朋友交谈
to try to determine everyone who might have had any contact with this person during the time that they could have been infectious. Ethelian Frank knew the young man who died had sought medical treatment for his tab wounds. Had a healthcare worker suture the young man's wounds and come into contact with his blood? Ethelia visited a lot of clinics trying to track down facilities the young man may have visited. She paged through logbooks of patient names with no luck. Then she got to one clinic. And I took this big dusty logbook and I opened it up and literally the page I opened it
以试图确定所有可能在这名年轻人具有传染性期间与他有过任何接触的人。埃塞莉娅和弗兰克知道，死去的年轻曾就他的刺伤寻求过医疗救护。是否有医护人员缝合了这名年轻人的伤口并接触了他的血液？埃塞莉娅走访了许多诊所，试图追踪这名年轻人可能去过的医疗点。她翻阅着患者姓名的日志，却一无所获。然后她来到了一家诊所。我拿起这本厚厚满是灰尘的日志并把它翻开， literalmente（字面意思）我翻开的那一页，
to, there's maybe 30 names to a page and I read down them and there he was at the bottom of the first page. A healthcare worker at this clinic had sutured the young man's knife wounds. Ethelia knew what she had to do. The most difficult part of these investigations come when you need to tell the clinicians and all of the staff who work in these healthcare facilities that someone with Ebola entered the facility. And I remember how nervous the individual was when I told him that the person he,
一页大概有30个名字，我往下读，他就排在第一页的最底部。这家诊所的一名医护人员缝合了这名年轻人的刀伤。埃塞莉娅知道她该做什么。这些调查中最困难的部分，在于你需要告诉这些医疗机构的临床医生和所有工作人员，曾有一名感染埃博拉的人进入过该场所。我记得当我告诉他，他缝合伤口的人当时埃博拉检测呈阳性时，那个人有多紧张。
he sutured had been positive for Ebola at the time. It's hard to imagine what he was going through. Can you recall what you told him and what he said? We were standing in the hallway and I told him that there's no easy way to tell anybody this. So we just told him very matter of fact that we needed to maintain daily contact and monitoring with him coming in for treatment the moment that you have symptoms and the reason I remember this so clearly is that he didn't
很难想象他当时经历了什么。你还记得你对他说过什么，他又说了什么吗？我们站在走廊里，我告诉他，无论对谁说这话都没有简单的方式。所以我们只是非常对事不对人地告诉他，我们需要与他保持日常联系和监测，一旦他出现症状就要来接受治疗，我之所以把这记得这么清楚，是因为他并没有
do that. He was very reluctant to go to an Ebola treatment unit. The health care worker refused to be quarantined. He insisted he'd followed all safety procedures as he bandaged the young man's wounds. He told a Thalia he'd followed all safety procedures as he bandaged the young man's wounds. He told the Thalia he'd get in touch if he started to have any symptoms. Ethelia knew there was a reason the healthcare worker had refused to come into an Ebola treatment unit. It had to do with a lack of trust in the system. In fact, the more Ethelia and Frank saw, the more they realized that Ebola wasn't
这样做。他非常不愿意去埃博拉治疗中心。这名医护人员拒绝被隔离。他坚持说自己在给年轻人包扎伤口时遵循了所有安全程序。他告诉埃塞莉娅，自己在给年轻人包扎伤口时遵循了所有安全程序。他告诉埃塞莉娅，如果开始出现任何症状，他会联系他们。埃塞莉娅知道这名医护人员拒绝去埃博拉治疗中心是有原因的。这与对系统缺乏信任有关。事实上，埃塞莉娅和弗兰克看到的越多，他们就越意识到埃博拉并不是
the only enemy they were fighting in Mondrovia. They were dealing with an epidemic of mistrust. After a long history of civil war and corruption, a lot of people in Liberia simply didn't trust the government or international organizations. When Ebola broke out, the government's first response was to try and control it using coercion. Coordining off sections of towns, it created panic. The government had attempted involuntary quarantine and they had a really bad experience in the slums of Manrovia. And so we talked about, you know,
他们在蒙罗维亚面临的唯一敌人。他们正在应对一场不信任的流行病。在经历了漫长的内战和腐败历史后，利比里亚的许多人根本不信任政府或国际组织。当埃博拉爆发时，政府的第一反应是试图通过高压手段来控制它。封锁城镇的某些部分，这引发了恐慌。政府曾尝试强制隔离，并且在蒙罗维亚的贫民窟有过非常糟糕的经历。所以我们讨论过，你知道的，
is this a viable strategy? We all agree, no, we can't use involuntary quarantine. This is not something that's going to build trust in the community. It's not a way to manage the outbreak. People also worry that if they did go into quarantine, they would never come out. Ethelia pointed to the construction of one of the largest Ebola treatment units in Liberia. And it was chaotic and difficult, and they built it all, and they forgot to put an accident.
这真的是一个可行的策略吗？我们一致认为，不行，我们不能使用强制隔离。这不是一种能在社区中建立信任的做法。这不是控制疫情的方法。人们还担心，如果他们真的被隔离了，就永远不会出来了。埃塞莉娅指着利比里亚最大的埃博拉治疗中心之一的建设。当时情况混乱且艰难，他们把中心建好了，却忘了留出一个出口。
They didn't build an exit because we weren't thinking about survivors at that time. And although this was many months later, many people understandably so thought that going to an Ebola treatment unit meant that you would not come home. Dealing with mistrust, the public health officials knew was central as they began to trace all the leads of this complex case. As a failure had been tracking down the healthcare worker, Frank had been pursuing a different strand of the investigation, tracking down the members of the young man's gang. This was a community that was not on the best terms with the government. You know, they were very suspicious of the government.
他们没有建出口，因为我们当时根本没有考虑幸存者。尽管这是好几个月后的事了，但许多人理所当然地认为，去埃博拉治疗中心就意味着你再也回不了家了。公共卫生官员知道，在他们开始追踪这个复杂案件的所有线索时，应对不信任感是核心任务。就在埃塞莉娅一直在追踪这名医护人员的同时，弗兰克一直在进行调查的另一条线索，追踪这个年轻人的帮派成员。这是一个与政府关系不太融洽的社区。你知道，他们对政府非常怀疑。
So it really is a trust building exercise to go into this community to piece together all these pieces of the story. Very quickly, Frank and Ethelia realized they were in over their heads. They needed help. So when we did the investigation, I went with this librarian. Fantastic librarian epidemiologist. Moussoka Fala. I'm Mussoka P. Fala. As a librarian, Mussoka Fala understood things far better than the Americans. He also understood the horrors of Ebola, first hand. The disease had killed his sister. Mussoka's first order of business was to help track down the young men in the gang. Surprisingly, they weren't hard to find, but they were scared. Scared that the police, who were still investigating
因此，进入这个社区并将这个故事的所有碎片拼凑起来，实际上是一个建立信任的过程。很快，弗兰克和埃塞莉娅意识到情况超出了他们的能力范围。他们需要帮助。所以我们在进行调查时，我和这位利比里亚人一起去的。一位出色的利比里亚流行病学家。穆苏卡·法拉。我是穆苏卡·P·法拉。作为一名流行病学家，穆苏卡·法拉对当地情况的理解远胜于美国人。他也第一手体会到了埃博拉的恐怖。这种疾病夺去了他姐姐的生命。穆苏卡的首要任务是协助追踪帮派中的年轻人。出人意料的是，他们并不难找，但他们很害怕。害怕警方（仍在将此案作为凶杀案调查）会因他们在刀战中所扮演的角色而逮捕他们。警方想进去。然而，如果我们允许近35名行事强硬的年轻人在外逍遥法外。这类似于《危险的角落》中发生的情节。等一下，等一下，等什么？等着其他人死吗？
the case as a homicide, would arrest them for their role in the knife fight. The police wanted to go in. However, if we allow the close to 35 young men who are all hard-wrapped on the loose. This is similar to what happened in panic in the streets. Wait a minute, wait a minute, wait for what? Somebody else to die? Friends suggested that there should be no arrests. Musoka says Frank sat down with the police. He told them that any investigation of the murder would send gang members into hiding
朋友们建议不应该进行逮捕。穆苏卡说，弗兰克坐下来与警方进行了交谈。他告诉警方，任何对谋杀案的调查都会迫使帮派成员躲藏起来，并可能进一步传播埃博拉病毒。这将允许埃博拉团队进入并进行谈判，以便我们能够进行接触，警察同意了，并且警方将放弃逮捕。这就是我们如何进去进行谈判的。每个人都告诉我们，正是这一点，才让公共卫生官员得以开始与帮派中的年轻人交谈。
and potentially spread Ebola further. This will allow the Ebola team to go in and negotiate so that we can have the contact and the police agreed and the police will view their arrest. And that's how we went into negotiate. And this, everyone told us, is what allowed public health officials to start talking to the young men in the gang. So, to recap, public health officials had tracked down the health care worker who treated the young man and identified all the people they could tell the young man had come into contact with.
所以，概括一下，公共卫生官员已经追踪到了治疗这名年轻人的医护人员，并确定了他们所能得知的所有与这名年轻人有过接触的人。
The epidemiologists quickly found themselves staring at a growing web. There were three important strands. First, the young men in the gang would have to be persuaded to enter an Ebola quarantine facility for 21 days. Second, there was a woman running a drug house who was connected to the gang. Gang members were in and out of her home all the time. Most worris him, the public health officials heard the woman was sick, and they thought that she might have Ebola. She had a hard day, we are for two days, and she was getting sick. Finally, there was one member of the gang they could not track down.
流行病学家很快发现自己面对着一个日益扩张的蛛网。这里有三个重要的线索。首先，必须说服帮派中的年轻人进入埃博拉隔离设施21天。其次，有一个经营毒窝的女性与该帮派有关联。帮派成员经常出入她的住所。最令人担忧的是，公共卫生官员听说这个女人病了，他们认为她可能感染了埃博拉。她已经病了两天了，而且病情正在加重。最后，还有一个帮派成员他们无法追踪到。
During the fight, this man had held down the stabbing victim as the blades came out and the blood splattered and Now fracking others found he'd run away. Oh, what was his name? His name ironically was time bomb Coming up how to stop the outbreak and find time bomb. Stay with us. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanthan. We're exploring how, in early 2015, epidemiologists tried to stop Ebola from spreading in a poor slum in Liberia. They had three fires to put out. Time bomb had gone underground. The rest of the
在斗争期间，这个人一直按住被刺的受害者，任由刀刃拔出、鲜血四溅。现在，弗兰克和其他人发现他已经逃跑了。哦，他叫什么名字？讽刺的是，他的名字叫定时炸弹。接下来是如何制止疫情并找到定时炸弹。请继续收听。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维丹塔姆。我们正在探讨在2015年初，流行病学家如何试图阻止埃博拉病毒在利比里亚一个贫困贫民窟中蔓延。他们有三处火灾要扑灭。“定时炸弹”已经潜入地下。其余的
gang had been identified, but were reluctant to be quarantined. And then there was the woman known as drug mama. She was the godmother of a drug den frequented by members of the gang. She was in her 30s and appeared to have symptoms that suggested Ebola. If Ebola struck the heart of the drug. She was in her 30s and appeared to have symptoms that suggested Ebola. If Ebola struck the heart of the drug den, it would spread very quickly through the community. Frank and Musoka realized they had to quickly run a test to get drug mama diagnosed, but they anticipated problems. Our dilemma was how do we approach such that she accepts us to do an Ebola test.
帮派成员已被查明，但不愿接受隔离。然后是那个被称为“毒妈”的女人。她是帮派成员经常光顾的毒窟的教母。她三十多岁，似乎出现了暗示埃博拉的症状。如果埃博拉袭击了毒窟的核心。她三十多岁，似乎出现了暗示埃博拉的症状。如果埃博拉袭击了毒窟的核心，它将以极快的速度在社区中传播。弗兰克和穆苏卡意识到他们必须迅速进行检测以诊断“毒妈”，但他们预料到了问题。我们的困境在于我们该如何接近她，让她接受埃博拉检测。
The mere mention of Ebola was sending people into a panic. If they told her they were worried she had Ebola, would she vanish and go underground? They didn't want to take the chance. So rather than take her into confidence, they decided to trick drug mama. It wasn't ideal, but they were dealing with the crisis. They had to improvise. So Frank being a smart guy he is, we stopped at a pharmacy and we bought him a mirror medicine.
仅仅提到“埃博拉”这个词就让人们陷入了恐慌。如果他们告诉她他们担心她感染了埃博拉，她会不会直接消失并潜入地下？他们不想冒这个险。因此，与其对她吐露实情，他们决定欺骗“毒妈”。这并不是理想的做法，但他们正在应对危机。他们必须随机应变。所以弗兰克是个聪明人，我们在药店停下来给她买了一些胃药。
And we went there at night and Frank said, ah, you're not so well. So we brought you some medicine. This is around 9 p.m. She said, yes. So Frank said, take this medicine. I will come back tomorrow and check on you. And so the goal was the next morning, we asked for her blood to go check if she had my liver and then we'll run the Ebola test.
我们是在晚上去的，弗兰克说：“啊，你身体不太好。所以我们给你带了点药。”当时大约是晚上9点。她说：“好的。”所以弗兰克说：“吃点药吧。我明天再来看你。”所以我们的目标是第二天早上，我们要求抽她的血去检查她是否有疟疾，然后我们再进行埃博拉检测。
The trick worked up to a point. The problem was the next morning, when they took drug mama to the hospital to get her blood drawn, they had to tell healthcare workers at the hospital what was going on so everyone would take proper precautions. A nurse got scared when they told her they wanted to test for Ebola. Drug Mama noticed the nurse acting oddly. And then she suspected something else. The drug Mama left and went back home and began angry with us.
这个计谋在一定程度上起作用了。问题出在第二天早上，当他们带“毒妈”去医院抽血时，他们不得不把情况告诉医院的医护人员，以便每个人都能采取适当的预防措施。当他们说想检测埃博拉时，一名护士吓坏了。“毒妈”注意到了护士反常的举动。然后她怀疑有别的事。毒妈离开了，回到了家，并开始对我们感到生气。
Musoka and Frank realized the trickery was backfiring. So they tried bribery. We sat down with her, we negotiated, and we told her we gave her $100 US. If she allowed us to do a blood draw at a house. So we took the blood, and at 7 p.m. that night, we got a response that she was negative. And we all went to bed reading a side of a release.
穆苏卡和弗兰克意识到这种诡计正在适得其反。于是他们尝试了贿赂。我们和她坐下来谈判，告诉她我们给她100美元现金，如果她允许我们在家里抽血的话。于是我们抽了血，当晚7点，我们得到了她结果为阴性的回复。我们所有人都松了一口气，上床睡觉了。
Frank and Musoka turned their focus to the second strand in the web, the young men in the gang. Patiently, they explained to the young men that they would be safe from police harassment in the Ebola treatment unit. We worked it out with them. We worked out an arrangement where they, if they agreed to come into the isolation facility, you know, the CDC, I think we ended up paying their families some support costs because they were no longer able to earn money for their families. And the government provided the families with food. And so it worked out really well. But even this was not enough.
弗兰克和穆苏卡将注意力转向了蛛网的第二条线索——帮派里的年轻人。他们耐心地向年轻人解释，在埃博拉治疗中心里，他们将免受警察的骚扰。我们和他们商量好了。我们达成了一项安排，如果他们同意进入隔离设施，你知道的，CDC，我想我们最终支付了他们家人一些生活补贴，因为他们无法再为家庭赚钱了。政府为这些家庭提供了食物。所以进展得非常顺利。但即便如此也还不够。
It turned out some of the young men were drug addicts. Frank realized he had to keep asking the government to bend the rules in the Ebola treatment unit or E.T.U. I told the government that we had to anticipate that some of these young men may be drug users and they may go into withdrawal if we put them in the E2U. And in fact, that was the case, about two to three days later. They were some of them getting agitated.
事实证明，有些年轻人是瘾君子。弗兰克意识到他必须不断请求政府在埃博拉治疗中心（ETU）放宽规则。我告诉政府，我们必须预料到这些年轻人中有些可能是吸毒者，如果我们把他们放进ETU，他们可能会出现戒断反应。事实上，情况确实如此，大约两到三天后。他们中的一些人开始变得情绪激动。
And somehow they found a way to support their needs or drugs. Did you have to do some of that to help them get what they needed to keep them in this facility where they could be quarantine? No, I didn't wouldn't see the seat and pay for that or do that But the government found a way for the communities for them So they were doing that so in but in some ways it's sort of an awkward situation for the government because in some ways You're asking the government to sort of look the other way while someone's doing something illegal here Yeah, I think that they, but at the same time they'd be like any withdrawal, they need a treatment. It wasn't a conventional treatment, that's for sure.
他们以某种方式找到了满足他们对毒品需求的方法？你是否必须做一些事情来帮助他们得到他们需要的东西，以将他们留在可以隔离他们的设施里？不，我不会看到这扇门并为此付钱或这样做，但政府为他们的社区找到了方法，所以他们这样做了。但在某些方面，这对于政府来说是一种尴尬的情况，因为在某种程度上，你要求政府睁一只眼闭一只眼，而有人在这里做非法的勾当。是的，我认为他们会这样做，但与此同时，他们会觉得任何戒断反应都需要治疗。这当然不是常规治疗。
It was art for public health officials to be sanctioning illegal drug use. But again, when you're in the middle of an unfolding catastrophe, you sometimes have to bend the rules. Even though CDC wasn't actually supplying anyone drugs, the arrangement produced lots of double takes. One day, a Liberian government minister turned to frang during a discussion and joked about the backdoor drug channel. And he says, and I understand that CDC is providing them with the marijuana. And I said, excuse me, sir, I said, I'd like to correct that. He said, CDC is not providing the marijuana,
对于公共卫生官员来说，默许非法吸毒是不正常的。但话说回来，当你身处一场正在展开的灾难之中时，你有时不得不打破常规。尽管CDC实际上并没有向任何人提供毒品，但这项安排还是引发了许多异样的目光。一天，利比里亚政府的一位部长在讨论中转向弗兰克，开玩笑地谈到了这条后门毒品通道。他说：“我听说CDC正在给他们提供大麻。”我说：“对不起，先生，我想纠正一下，”我说，“CDC没有提供大麻，但我们提供的是可卡因。”
but we're providing the copain. Incredibly, the epidemiologist actually managed to quarantine the gang members. These were young men who no one thought would listen to the authorities. But by reposing trust in them and treating the young men as partners, the public health officials had found a solution that seemed to work better than coercion or trickery. Still, this wasn't the end. There was a third strand of the web they had to track down. Time bomb. Time bomb became very elusive. We could not find time bomb. At first, gang members did not
令人难以置信的是，这位流行病学家竟然设法隔离了帮派成员。这些都是年轻人，没有人认为他们会听从当局的指挥。但通过重新对他们产生信任，并把这些年轻人当作合作伙伴，公共卫生官员找到了一种似乎比强迫或欺骗更有效的解决方案。尽管如此，这并不是终点。他们还有蛛网的第三条线索需要追踪。定时炸弹。定时炸弹变得非常难以捉摸。我们找不到定时炸弹。起初，帮派成员不想
want to tell Musoka of Frank where time bomb was. But as we built friendship and rapport with the other criminals, one of them took us to his house. There, they found a young man, a young woman, and a baby. The epidemiologist asked the young man if he was time bomb. He said, I'm not time bomb. Time bomb is going out. I'm his younger brother. But if he comes back, I will let you know. Then I say, OK, thank you very much.
告诉穆苏卡或弗兰克定时炸弹在哪里。但随着我们与其他罪犯建立起友谊和融洽关系，其中一人带我们去了他的家。在那里，他们发现了一个年轻男子、一个年轻女人和一个婴儿。流行病学家问这个年轻人他是不是“定时炸弹”。他说：“我不是定时炸弹。定时炸弹出门了。我是他弟弟。但他如果回来，我会告诉你。”然后我说：“好的，非常感谢。”
It was at this point that Musoko and Frank did something very kind and very wise that led to a breakthrough in the case. Your wife had a young baby and I remember giving them a wife at $100 and said, go ahead and buy milk for the baby, feed the baby and we'll take care of you. Something changed in the young man's demeanor. After I did that, he turned to me and said to me, I am Tom Boom. Frank and Musoka told Time-Bomb and his wife
正是在这个时候，穆苏卡和弗兰克做了一件非常善良且非常明智的事情，促成了案件的突破。你妻子有个小婴儿，我记得给了他们妻子100美元现金，说：“拿着去给孩子买奶粉，把孩子喂饱，我们会照顾你们的。”这个年轻人的态度发生了某种变化。在我做完这些之后，他转过身对我说：“我就是定时炸弹。”弗兰克和穆苏卡告诉“定时炸弹”和他的妻子
that they would be back that night. They promised they would return with more food. Frank came to me with the food and said, Musoka, we need to go to meet this guy. This was in a ghetto. I went with Musoka and it was like 10 o'clock at night. There was no electricity. This place was pitch black. We had to go and drive to the grass. This was like a slump community. It's known to have gangsters and that's why the friend was emphasizing
他们当晚会回来。他们承诺会带着更多的食物回来。弗兰克带着食物来找我，说：“穆苏卡，我们需要去见这个人。”这是一个贫民窟。我和穆苏卡一起去了，当时大约是晚上10点。没有电。这个地方漆黑一片。我们不得不开车驶入草地。这就像一个贫民窟社区。这里以黑帮横行而闻名，这就是为什么那位朋友一直在强调
that we had to keep our word. We had to trust us. This was the key. So we brought food to him and his family. I think a couple of sex to rise in things. As we walked towards them and the saw us come to a rise on our pseudo, for some reason it trusted us. And it came to the car and helped us take the rise. Frank and Musoka gently asked time bomb, whether he was willing to come to the Ebola treatment facility
我们必须信守诺言。我们必须信任彼此。这就是关键。所以我们给他和他的家人带了食物。我想大概有几袋大米之类的东西。当我们朝他们走去，他们看到我们带着大米来到他们的简易房时，出于某种原因，他们信任了我们。他走到车前，帮我们搬大米。弗兰克和穆苏卡温和地问“定时炸弹”，他是否愿意去埃博拉治疗中心
to be quarantined. Timebomb said he wasn't ready to do that. Frank and Masoka said they understood that they were willing to trust him to do the right thing. If you get sick, you call us and he said I will do that. I trust you guys. And so I think it was a matter of building a trust and comfort level for him to talk to us. In the end, none of the young gang members contracted Ebola, not even time bomb. The cluster did not spread in the ghetto.
接受隔离。“定时炸弹”说他还没准备好这样做。弗兰克和穆苏卡说他们理解，他们愿意相信他会做正确的事。如果你生病了，你给我们打电话。他说我会这么做的。我相信你们。所以我觉得这是一个为他建立信任和舒适感以便与我们交谈的问题。最后，年轻的帮派成员中没有人感染埃博拉，连“定时炸弹”也没有。疫情并没有在贫民窟蔓延。
Drug Mama recovered from her illness. Only one person connected with the cluster was affected. The medical worker who'd sutured up the young man's wounds, the one that went into hiding after a thalia talked to him, he came down with Ebola-related symptoms. Eventually, he did seek treatment, but it was too late. He died, unfortunately, in the Streets. At the end of that movie, the hero, a public health worker, ends up in a warehouse with the criminals who are carrying the deadly plague.
“毒妈”从病情中恢复了过来。只有一个与该聚集性病例有关的人受到了影响。那个缝合了年轻人伤口的医护人员，也就是在埃塞莉娅找他谈话后躲藏起来的那个人，他出现了与埃博拉相关的症状。最终，他确实寻求了治疗，但为时已晚。不幸的是，他死在了街头。在那部电影的结尾，英雄——一名公共卫生工作者，与携带着致命鼠疫的罪犯们一起陷入了一个仓库中。
He pleads for them to hand over their guns. Come off now, surrender! And I promise nothing will happen to you! But... They get into a climactic shootout and the criminals are killed. The public health workers in Liberia never solved things with guns. And really, when it came down to it, Ethelia says, they achieved some of their best results without coercion or trickery. Building those invisible but very real bonds of trust took time, but it was essential
他恳求他们交出武器：“住手吧，投降吧！我保证你们不会有事的！”但是……他们爆发了一场激烈的枪战，罪犯们被击毙了。利比里亚的公共卫生工作者从没有用枪解决问题。说到底，埃塞莉娅说，他们是在没有强迫或欺骗的情况下取得了最好的成果。建立那些无形但却非常真实的信任纽带需要时间，但这对于阻止疫情至关重要。
to stopping an outbreak. When it comes down to what we were asking people to do, either to trust the healthcare system or to trust, the government enough to agree to this voluntary precautionary isolation. That's an extraordinarily difficult thing to do. You're asking people to leave their friends and family for 21 days, or we were asking people to change their burial customs. And it's difficult. It can sound simple, and I know that I spoke to people here who would say,
当我们要求人们做某事时，无论是信任医疗系统，还是信任政府到足以同意这种自愿的预防性隔离。这是一件极其困难的事情。你是在要求人们离开他们的朋友和家人21天，或者我们是在要求人们改变他们的葬礼习俗。这很难。这听起来很简单，我知道我在这里和一些人交谈过，他们会说，
I don't understand why can't they just change the way they bury the dead, or change the way they care for their family members if they're sick, but as a mother, I can't imagine not touching my child if he was sick and not trying to provide comfort. So it's really understanding what it is that's that's driving people. You have to understand their context, their concerns, and their needs. I think it's about interpersonal relationships. You have to be honest and straightforward about what you need and why. And most importantly, I think you need to be human. This episode of Hidden Brain was produced by Chris Benderev and edited by Tara Boyle and Jenny Schmidt.
我不明白为什么他们不能改变埋葬死者的方式，或者如果家人生病了为什么不能改变照顾他们的方式，但作为一个母亲，我无法想象如果我的孩子生病了却不去触摸他，不试图给他安慰。所以真正重要的是理解驱使人们做出这些行为的原因。你必须了解他们的处境、他们的担忧和他们的需求。我认为这关乎人际关系。你必须诚实、直率地说明你需要什么以及为什么需要。最重要的是，我认为你需要有人情味。本期《隐藏的大脑》由克里斯·本德雷夫制作，塔拉·博伊尔和珍妮·施密特编辑。
Our staff includes Maggie Pennman and Renee Clarre. We had original music from Rampteen Arab Louis. To find more Hidden Brain, go to Facebook and Twitter and listen from my stories on your local public radio station. Our unsung hero this week doesn't work at NPR. He's Tom Frieden, director of the Centers for Disease Control and Prevention. He got in touch some time ago to say he loved the show, but wanted to know why we weren't doing more stories about public health.
我们的员工包括玛吉·佩恩曼和蕾妮·克拉尔。我们的原创音乐来自拉姆蒂恩·阿拉布卢伊。想了解更多《隐藏的大脑》，请访问Facebook和Twitter，并在当地公共广播电台上收听我的故事。我们这周的无名英雄不在NPR工作。他是汤姆·弗里登，美国疾病控制与预防中心主任。他前段时间联系我们，说他很喜欢这个节目，但想知道为什么我们没有做更多关于公共健康的报道。
I told him those stories tended to be a little dry. He said, wait a minute, I've got a great one for you. Tom, you were right. This was a great story. If you have an idea for a Hidden Brain episode, a topic with interesting ideas and great characters, drop us a line that HiddenBrain at npr.org. I'm Shankar Vedantam, and this is NPR. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我告诉他，那些故事往往有点枯燥。他说：“等一下，我有一个很好的故事讲给你听。”汤姆，你说得对。这是一个很棒的故事。如果你对《隐藏的大脑》某一期节目有想法，一个包含有趣理念和优秀人物的主题，请发邮件至HiddenBrain@npr.org联系我们。我是香卡·维丹塔姆，这里是NPR。谢谢收听。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。